the iPhone 15 Pro Design leaks have been
insane over the past couple of months
with various potential feature leaks
going back and forth between either
coming for sure or not coming at all and
there was even one leak that was
completely wrong from the very beginning
but the truth has now came to light
finally confirming the precise
production model design that we're
actually going to be getting this
September so let's jump right into the
final leaks and changes now going way
back a year and a half ago in 2021 we
had a major redesigned leak coming from
John Prosser for the iPhone 14 getting
an iPhone 4 style redesign as you're
seeing right here with protruding glass
in the front and back with flush camera
lenses making this absolutely beautiful
new design he showed off many different
angles like this one showing the older
circular Style buttons in a really
really nice and unique design that was
so much different than what Apple has
been using since the iPhone 6. however
in March of 2022 Max Weinbach released
the official CAD renders for the iPhone
14 pro and pro Max and John Prosser was
wrong it was basically the same design
all over again with a bigger camera bump
but with the dynamic Island so the
general consensus was that this brand
new redesign was delayed an additional
year until the iPhone 15 series maybe
even the ultra that I tweeted out here
and I worked with renders by Shailesh to
create these absolutely beautiful
renders here with rounded glass merging
into the flat sides with protruding
lenses right on top of this flat glass
panel which looks absolutely beautiful
especially in this brand new bronze
color but the no Max Weinbach once again
poured cold water all over those
redesigned leaks basically showing the
official case cads right here which were
created by Ian zelbo and you can see the
design looks almost the same with one
very unique touch the edges are now
rounded into the flat glass front and
back however there are actually two
other major feature changes that we were
not expecting that totally changed
everything the first one was this
absolutely massive camera bump basically
being as thick as the phone itself
particularly showing off this inner
black ring sticking out much further
than expected and then the second one
was this unified volume button insert
right here which zone attack actually
talked about showing off that it's now
going to be one unified button and this
actually connected to something Michiko
said back in October where the iPhone 15
Pro would have three taptic engines
featuring solid state buttons and then
that grew in January saying that for
sure we're getting non-moving buttons on
the 15 Pro and then we even got
additional information saying that
there's going to be a custom chip that
can adjust for the sensitivity to cater
for cases and gloves so we started
getting new renders showing off that
unified volume rocker and unknowns 21
actually showed off the official design
with this kind of slit or Ridge in the
middle Discerning between the plus and
minus and he even showed off the
internal part that was supposed to
control all of this but the no minchiko
came out and said we're no longer
getting those solid state buttons no
longer getting that unified volume
button due to design issues making it
get delayed until the iPhone 16 Pro so
now it basically is going back to having
the regular buttons but on the plus side
the new programmable action button which
is replacing the new Switch is sticking
around so we have confirmation that that
is going to stay which is really nice at
least we get something new on this new
15 Pro and then finally just last week
we got updated cads exclusively from
nine to five Mac and Ian zobo revealing
basically the final confirmed changes
that are happening as you can see we
have both volume buttons back just like
they were before we have the new action
button right here on the left which
replaces the old 14 pro mute switch that
you can see right here and the final
change is that that massive camera bump
on the 15 Pro is actually gone it is now
the same as a 15 Pro Max no longer that
massive now it looks much more
reasonable it's definitely bigger than
the one in the 14 pro and 14 team pro
Max but it is no longer as massive and
that was confirmed by unknowns 21
basically saying that the massive camera
bump on the 15 Pro never existed at any
point in development it was never
planned either it was basically a lie or
a trap or some kind of accident it was
basically staying consistent from the
very beginning so now with that said
with all of that settled and confirmed
here are the new cads and it's basically
very similar to the 14 pro except for
the rounded edges which are going to
feel better in your hand and we have the
new action button those are going to be
the major changes however the one that
I'm very excited for is the thin bezels
apparently the 15 Pro Max is gonna break
the record for the thinnest bezels on
any smartphone being only 1.5
millimeters thick and right on cue Ian
zubble created these final renders
showing the confirmed bezel size of on
the 15 pro and pro Max and that is
absolutely mind-blowing on top of that
we also got confirmation that the 15
models are using more efficient OLED
display driver chips manufactured on a
newer 28 nanometer process compared to
40 nanometer so that is going to be
using less power which will help it not
overheat as fast and have less display
dimming issues and it's going to help
with battery life as well which we
already had reports of the best battery
life that we've seen because of the new
a17 3 nanometer chip so that's going to
be a huge difference and then of course
we can't forget one of the biggest
changes which is the titanium finish
which looks absolutely beautiful in this
render by Ian zelbo and USBC which is
finally coming and replacing the
lightning port on all of the models but
the more interesting thing is that the
regular 15s are getting slow USB 2.0
speeds and the pro models are getting
USB 3.0 according to what unknowns 21
can recall which is a lot faster than it
currently is right now on top of that he
also said it seems likely that we're
getting the Periscope camera on the pro
Max even though the massive camera bump
leak is gone we're still getting the
Periscope on the pro Max model which is
great and finally we got some updated
leaks from renders by Shailesh basically
showing you guys the confirmation of the
final design right here with the action
button both of the volume buttons the
titanium the larger camera bumps no
longer as massive as it was before and
this new deep red color which looks
absolutely amazing and you can see that
titanium texture here as well this looks
absolutely
incredible and from the side you can now
see that nice curve which is going to
make it feel nicer in your hands very
excited for that and Bam you could see
the very thin bezels right here as well
with the 2.5 D glass so that does it
those are the final confirmed leak
details on the design this is what we
should expect come September so let me
know your thoughts down in the comment
section below click subscribe to
subscribe to this channel for more
videos like this one thanks for watching
and we'll see you in the next video
foreign